the right likes to say national
healthcare systems are bad bad bad
Canada's terrible the UK is a disaster
it's all bad all in defense of this
immoral for-profit employer connected
health care system that we have in the
United States the DC think tank known as
the Commonwealth Fund did a study of the
health care systems of eleven wealthy
countries and it found may be a surprise
to some of you maybe not that the
American system is the worst by multiple
measures and this includes countries
like the UK Australia Canada Germany
Sweden the UK's national health services
was the best in many categories the five
categories evaluated were access to care
equality of access for people of
different incomes administrative
efficiency how well the care process
works and how good the health outcomes
are now it's not all a panacea for these
other countries right so like for
example the UK system was first overall
but was tenth in terms of health care
outcomes but the big consistency was
that the u.s. did terribly in every
single area access to care the u.s. was
a disaster for example 44% of low-income
people in the United States have trouble
accessing care compared to only 7% of
low-income people in the UK and notably
the report says that there's been some
improvement as a result of Obamacare but
this is more evidence that Obamacare is
no incredible wonderful appending of the
healthcare status quo it's a slight
improvement or it has slowed down the
worsening of some areas of the system
but it's no massive victory and in total
in overall performance the u.s. was dead
last the leaders were as I mentioned the
UK was first followed by Australia and
the Netherlands where the US turn up at
the top of the list of countries well in
terms of how much we spend we are
leading the way and this relates to many
many issues this relates to the fact
that we have a system that seeks profit
we've got a total bureaucratic
inefficient
see due to the medical billing and
insurance system that we have it's a
total train wreck we spend more than
every other country on the list and we
have the worst overall healthcare system
how can anyone be proud of that
you know right-wingers go on and on
about how America is number one I don't
think we're number one in this category
again number 11 here this should be a
point of national pride right I mean to
the right-wing Patriots wouldn't it be
nice to be able to be really proud of
how well our health care system works
instead of like how many bombs we have
or something like that or does that
point of view make me a beta male I
don't know maybe it does that I think it
would be nice to be proud of our health
care system seems like you want poor
people to survive in this country there
are people to live longer and they see
perspective to have and know no country
is perfect some will point out that a
waiting times for some procedures are
longer in some of the countries on the
list
others might point out that costs might
be lower in other countries because
maybe nurses aren't paid well or
something like that there are always
problems but this study pretty nicely
sums up sort of like the net impact of
all aspects of the system and it's just
absolutely vile and disgusting and I
want to remind you I've said this before
there is something called HR 676 out
there HR 676 is a house proposal called
the expanded and improved Medicare for
all Act and it basically is single-payer
health care not in a literal sense what
it actually would do is take the
Medicare system we have which has done a
better job of holding costs not as high
lower might be a bit of a stretch but
from going as high it's a system that
works quite well in many ways the idea
would be to expand Medicare to everybody
this has been proposed a number of times
by House Democrats it basically never
has a shot at going anywhere
but it is there it is there and a lot of
people don't know about it and you can
go to who is my representative calm
figure out who does represent you in
both the Senate and the house start
making calls send faxes do whatever you
want I mean it seems like whenever we
talk about overhauling the health care
system you're going to have legislation
that's hundreds of pages long you know
it's not going to be this
but you're effectively just making the
age requirement for Medicare zero and
that's a lot easier to do than to maybe
pass Obamacare or the American
healthcare act all you're doing is going
into Medicare and this is a slight
oversimplification but changing the
minimum age at which you can get
Medicare it is a very interesting
proposal that is completely dead in the
water unfortunately but still HR 676
just talked about it call your
representatives about it